la première élection municipale le débat
[Musique]
bienvenue sur les antennes et des écrans
internet de martinique la première pour
un nouveau débat des élections
municipales et communautaires 2020
consacré pour cette édition à la ville
de sainte anne donc quatre listes sont
en lice à l'heure nous parlons car
rappelons que le début de la période
d'enregistrement officiel des listes est
fixée à lundi prochain mais oui déjà
le 10 février nous avons donc ainsi les
quatre candidats têtes de listes à
sainte-anne autour de la table avec
jean-marc parti à côté de moi sans plus
tarder nous les présentons oui bienvenue
à toutes et à tous les candidats de
sainte anne qui sont quatre pour le
moment comme le disait mais entre un car
oui ce ne sont pas des candidats
officiels mais ce sont des candidats
déclarés qui sont déjà en campagne
par ordre alphabétique tout d'abord
gilles bayle mots bonsoir monsieur b le
monde
bonsoir monsieur partie bonsoir monsieur
caruge bonsoir aux candidats aux autres
candidats ils vont soit aux saintes
année zéro cette année vous êtes âgé de
48 ans vous êtes cadre dirigeant d'un
organisme privé relevant de la cité m
satellite de la collectivité actuelle la
martinique et vous êtes à la tête de la
liste que nouvel élan pour sainte-anne
éclairant notre ville
jean-michel j'ai mieux 62 ans le gérant
de société vous êtes à la tête de la
liste sainte anne à coeur vous êtes le
maire sortant vous avez été élu donc en
2014 mais vous aviez été candidat à des
élections municipales déjà à sainte anne
en 2001 et 2002 vous êtes également 4e
vice-président sortant de l'espace sud
ensuite nous avons toujours par ordre
alphabétique que monsieur joël joseph
maire helix âgé de 59 ans qui est
employé cadre de la fonction publique
territoriale qui mène la liste
l'alternative synthèse et je précise que
vous êtes également président de la spa
marc en congé le temps de cette campagne
électorale et à côté de lui
pierre aillères 68 ans lui-même militant
du modemas et de la socama
vous êtes technicien territorial
retraités et puis vous menez vous
conduisait la liste agir ensemble pour
sainte-anne
voilà donc pour la présentation des
quatre candidats dans ce débat a réalisé
soit quand même cette année allez-y
c'est vrai que je suis là pour ça voilà
je salue tout le monde qui est si
présent et particulièrement les cette
année mais cette année ce qui nous
écoutent les martiniquais aussi voilà
j'espère que ce débat effectivement pour
le lober mis trop de se renseigner et
abu dhabi bataille sur la vie de la cité
baptisé moi c'est avant tout je salue
cherche à 1h smic est tous les auditeurs
et surtout les sainte anne et saint
jeannaise qui je pense est à l'écouté et
porte une attention particulière à ce
débat voilà et pour être équitable donc
jean-michel j'ai mieux saluer aussi ce
qu'il vous en coûtera tout le monde voit
aussi lancement de la martinique est bon
soit aussi aux sainte anne et je
voudrais rapide me le dire merci merci
parce qu'en 2014
ils ont osé ils ont osé le changement la
transformation et aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une chanson mais c'est
important quand même de leur dire merci
puisque je n'ai pas eu l'occasion de
beaucoup dire merci en tout cas merci
d'avoir osé mais aussi de faire c'est
dans cette grande ville cette belle
ville que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
voilà et moi je voulais préciser que
claudine était le biais l'état la
réalisation donc de cette émission de ce
débat jean-marc vous nous brosser
maintenant quelques lignes le portrait
de cette commune de l'extrême sud de
l'île oui voilà sainte-anne bien connu
qui l'intérieur nos abris sont non
seulement aux auditeurs de symptômes
vous internautes également de la terre
entière et peut-être même qui c'est au
tour de la terre puisqu'il ya plusieurs
hypothèses sur le peuplement de
l'univers mais trêve de plaisanterie
revenons en terre à terre à sainte anne
qui est la commune de l'extrême sud de
l'île d'ailleurs c'est la seule commune
de martinique me semble-t-il qui n'a
qu'une seule commune limitrophe
en l'occurrence le marin toutes les
autres communes de martinique ont moins
deux autres communes qui leur sont
limitrophes bras c'est une particularité
géographique pourquoi pas si je vous dis
cap chevalier barrière à lacroix barrez
tôt évidemment caritan vous me répondrez
sainte-anne et donc les symptômes qui
s'étend sur à peu près 3842 ha c'est
l'une des villes les plus étendue du
territoire ensuite au 1er janvier
l'insee avait comptabilisé environ 4300
personnes qui habitaient sainte-anne y
en avait environ 4600 il ya cinq ans
4700 il ya dix ans s'étonne également
connaît leur reflux démographique la
population il diminue comme dans la
plupart des communes de martinique il
n'y a que deux communes où la population
a augmenté ces cinq dernières années
je rappelle que la commune est
représentée par deux délégués au conseil
communautaire de la communauté
d'agglomération de l'espace sud qui en
comptent 46 et 27 conseillers municipaux
et conseillère municipale seront à
elliant les 15 et pourquoi pas le 22
mars prochain en cas de second tour
cette année dans une commune de sportif
bien connu je ne vais pas citer les
nombreux noms mais on peut citer
quelques clubs notamment le plus récent
c'est en cap 110 en handball qui fait
les beaux jours du championnat de
handball et puis surtout la renaissance
qui a été trois fois champion de
martinique qui viennent quarantaine
d'années messieurs vous vous en souvenez
peut-être sauf peut-être monsieur b les
mots qui était encore alors qu'une autre
contre à ce moment là mais je spéciaux
qu'il se souvient des instants de la
renaissance mo'fo grand père était
président fondateur de la renaissance au
modèle vous et bien voilà nous sommes
encore dans l'histoire alors en parlant
d'histoire c'est une commune qui est
l'une des plus anciennes implantations
du temps de la colonie de 1690 il y
avait des jeunes chapelle qui s'est
transformée en église puis en paroisse
avait déjà 700 habitants c'est un avant
et 17 cents avant les années 1700 qui
habitait toute la périphérie du site
août la colle à la future commune de
sainte anne dont la fête patronale et le
27 juillet et puis parmi les
particularités historiques une très
forte religiosité puisqu'il ya un
pèlerinage consacré à notre dame de la
salette qui ont organisé le 19 septembre
de chaque année cela depuis près de 150
ans le premier a eu lieu en 1877 ce qui
ne nous rajeunit pas en fait je termine
pas en quelques points de vue à voir les
plages on va pas les citer toutes mais
il ya les salines et puis tout les ans
un an soir ans car habitant en strabo un
second stick que sais-je encore il ya
les temps des salines qui a une
particularité géologique de la savane
pétrification il y a également l'héroïne
de l'habitation grivko et puis en fait
l'église notre dame dont je viens de
parler qui est inscrite à l'inventaire
des monuments historiques on pourrait
parler pendant une heure de temps encore
auzits et vous avez dit des plats
célèbre effectivement celle des salines
mais là pour les parent élu maire de
lille
je voulais surtout vous avez vous avez
oublié de dire que c'est la première
terre émergée de la martinique en effet
ce n'est pas un oubli mais il fallait la
présentation depuis rectifié pour
thématique la presqu'île de la caravelle
et sainte anne
non c'est les deux les deux les deux en
même temps alors je voulais pression
c'est l'explication je partirai pas pour
les martiniquais qui nous écoutent oui
il n'ya pas de la rustica cette année
donc il faut y aller ce millier voilà
c'est très important
on a parlé dans ce moustique non chardy
a tenté comme plage est bon mais voulait
dire fonds moustiques certainement
séance moustiques mais c'était donc ce
rapide que nous sommes de l'imprécision
rapidement dit alors là c'est
jean-michel j'ai mieux qu'ils parlent
que la population est de recenser et
nous sommes à 4400 4444 habitants
aujourd'hui d'accord ces documents
qu'ils quittent arrivé récemment à
merris et ainsi de pouvoir glisser vous
dire que nous avons une progression
démographique j'avais dire c'était
d'accord 4444
voilà vous dites à progression par
rapport à un camp parce que ces
relations et l'autre 4298 aujourd'hui
nous avons en population 4444
on est encore vivants 150 habitants de
plus d'un quand c'est bien deux ans va
bien nous voilà alors sainte anne où
s'est rendu en reportage bien kkr et o
afin de recueillir les sentiments et les
regards des habitants sur leur commune
quelques semaines donc de ces échéances
municipales nous écoutons tout de suite
et puis vous réagirez ensuite
spontanément de cette année d'ailleurs
et puis ici on a pas d'entreprise online
c'est cela qu'on attende prochain mieux
qui puisse mettre en place tout ce qu'il
faut deux autres que les investisseurs
puissent investir s'étale tout en
protégeant c'est un conte de travail et
les coûts deviennent amis frères soeurs
à sainte-anne surtout au col et le
peuple russes d'animation ou
de retour ce jeune polonais de mettre au
travail
regardez il ya là oui il ya le cimetière
quoi de mieux travailler mais bien celle
améliorer la commune pourquoi il y avait
plus de clients on s'attendait à rien du
tout nous madame je n'ai eu beau jeu
alors pour moi tout vent lui n'y a pas
de gêne c'est vraiment comme ça va nous
n'avons que les vieux parle disait que
c'était toujours animés ont fait pas
parce que le beauf aller se garer aux
salines presque ont du coup voilà c'est
ça qu'on attend la plage qui est payante
de la pac man est bon c'est dommage
essentiellement pour les jeunes comme
des attractions phares un autre reporter
du basket fusent animations pour les
jeunes en tout cas y'a pas suffisamment
la bibliothèque paysans des choses pour
les jeunes
culturellement même des jeux et
intellectuelles et il faudrait
développer ça parce que faut pas penser
qu'aux anciens j'attends quelqu'un qui
soit honnête ne pas être moteur au score
on est maire on peut pas donner des
rendez vous aux gens et peut ne pas
assumer
voilà messieurs quelques éléments ça n'a
pas valeur de sondage
évidemment ce sont des propositions de
cette année c'est de cette année aurait
accueilli il ya quelques jours par notre
patrie ce bien car eto'o qui souhaitent
réagir tout le monde va s'exprimer
dessus
we have mans monsieur joseph merrick je
vois que oui à vous inspire bien sûr
lorsque le disque paraît de de plus doté
de bibliothèques jeudi que mais ce sont
des souvenirs qui reviennent vous avez
j'ai connu la mjc ce qu'on appelle la
maison des jeunes et de la culture
c'est un os c'est là que j'ai connu ma
première biotechs et a obtenu mon
premier livre parce que cette
bibliothèque de de la magie c'est la
maison des jeunes et de la culture c'est
tout mon passé
c'est là que je me suis fondu y avait
toujours de la bibliothèque
monsieur les réductions annoncées les
murs de la mjc sont là des aussi
maintenant l'espace et gilles bellemare
cgpme
cette biotech n'y est plus et lorsque je
parle de la mjc la maison des jeunes et
de la culture
tout part de cette maison parce que
c'est là où j'ai pris ma première
cotisation au premier tacle de membres
de membres d'associations voix parlée au
village je voulais juste préciser que
c'est un exercice qui appelle un
commentaire pas trop long oui oui bien
sûr ce que nos paroles c'est vous
épuisez votre temps de parole trop vite
évidemment sur la fin de l'émission
pourrait plus parler donc voilà donc je
vous empêche pas de parler je rappelle
simplement qu'il ne faut pas être trop
trop long dans les interventions
voilà donc je voulais dire depuis 1970
il y avait dix ans je prenais déjà ma
grotte de membres d'associations donc
j'étais déjà dans l'engagement
associatif depuis l'âge de 10 ans
sérieux qu'est ce que vous avez entendu
oui très bien ce qu'on a entendu on n'a
pas beaucoup parlé du passé on a parlé
de puteaux du prise en ce qui concerne
tous les sept années et particulièrement
le travail
et puis l'investissement la création
d'entreprise à l'intérieur de ces dames
et lorsque nous voyons là les
problématiques qui se posent à 70
la diminution quoi qu'on en dise la
diminution de la population en âge de
travailler et l'augmentation d'une
certaine population de plus de 60 ans
nous avons déjà la part par ce micro
trottoir les différents aspects de notre
programme merci monsieur belmont donc
c'est vrai que en entendant les
réactions se rend compte de la réalité
aucune zone artisanale ou commerciale
incertaine et aucune bibliothèque ya
aucune médiathèque et au que gymnase ya
aucun terrain de basket ya aucune maison
cartier et aucune piscine publique
il ya envoya aucun équipement
structurant est difficile ah bon je n'ai
pas dit ça mais comme vous faites une
longue liste de ce qu'il n'y a pas je
n'y a pas de salle funéraire n'y a pas
de salle de fêtes c'est la réalité cette
année on sent et c'est vrai que ce que
les jeunes veulent c'est se retrouver
c'est du travail c'est un logement on va
parler plus tard du quota de la loyère
c'est sru en matière de logements
sociaux mais il manque deux cent
soixante et un logement à cette année
donc qui a énormément de difficulté est
aujourd'hui le nouvel élan qu'on veut
impulser c'est pour recréer cette
dynamique
jean-michel j'ai mieux donc oui je suis
maire sortant surpris de tant de est
recommandé de jeu des san it et parce
qu'effectivement c'était une personne
ici sur le plateau n'habitent pas
s'étonne alors ils réagissaient
recueillis par notre reporter même s'ils
réagissent mais ici quelques a parlé de
de netteté la politique doit d'abord
être une politique honnête et nous avons
le sms et service municipal sport et
culture qui gérait à sainte anne
nous avons relooké l'ensemble du
bâtiment ex mjc d'accord ça a été fait
nous avons aussi une bibliothèque un
coin lecture au sein du sms et à
communiquer par un terrain de football
qui existent aussi
nous avons eu ce que je vous dise nous
avons un financement ctm hauteur ville
et ses auteurs de 150000 euros
tenant compte de l'espace de jeux de
l'ère de handball nous avons décidé
effectivement demandé c'était pas
possible du point de transférer ces
sommes pour voir améliorer le comment
dirais-je le l'air de jeu nous avons là
bois espace aussi à barretos alors quand
on me dit qu'il ya pas de de commandes
espaces souvent d'équipement je me
demande où vivent ces personnes
la plage payante si je peux rapidement
engagé c'est pas que ça dépend des que
moi la page serait nettement ouverte
mais nous avons quatre sikhs
personnellement qui travaillent sur
cette plage qui n'est 3 cette plage
parce que nous recevons énormément de
tourisme le monde avec l'ajout de
protéines de haute mer et puisqu'il
s'agit de sa d'accord et nous avons
comme nous avons récupéré sept ces
parkings d'accord nous avons baissé sur
les tarifs je rappelle que de 2012
rapidement et pardonnez moi il faut que
je de 2012 ça fait c'est un des thèmes
oui la gestion des plages qu'on va en
parler mais je termine depuis 2012
d'accord 2002 jusqu'à 2015 nous n'avons
reçu que cinq mille euros de buc et
l'exploitation des prises par la ville
d'accord nous en gagnons des 70000 euros
alors j'ai oublié la question posée mais
où passe où est passée cette somme c'est
le différentiel passé ou de l'après
question qu'il faut se poser bon ben
voilà c'est une transition jean ba a
tout juste fait notre première notre
premier thème c'est l'un des débats qui
reviennent en seulement la campagne mais
qui occupent dix en dix ans la vie
publique si j'ai dit oui à cet angle
c'est la gestion de la plage agissions
du littoral et notamment une polémique
est née il ya environ deux ans par le
fait que la galaxie municipal a accordé
à une association les glénan basé en
bretagne la gestion de la plage de la
pointe noire et ceux qui a fait pousser
les hauts cris à l'opposition municipale
mais à d'autres personnes
sur le mode mais quand même il ya des
martiniquais ya des associations il ya
des entreprises qui sont capables de le
faire pourquoi nous n'avons pas choisi
des gens de leur pays ou de la commune
pour le maire garcin malsa s'était même
fendu d'un courrier je crois adressé à
je ne sais qui une autorité gelé la soul
sous les yeux on va le retrouver
le temps que je retrouve
voilà en tout cas il a fait une lettre
l'ancien maire monsieur garcin malsa
dans laquelle il exprimait sa
désapprobation par rapport à cette
décision de donner un club nautique des
glénans délégation la réaction oui vous
étiez attaqués à ce moment là je suis
d'attaqué vous savez je ne peux pas non
plus à chaque attaque d'accord
insignifiante réagir le glénan c'est
quoi nous voulons donner une qualité
nous voulons former les jeunes même de
le cas du développement durable la mère
doit être investi depuis 25 ans est ce
que cette mère était investi la vacation
le projet odyssea dit des choses très
fortes
il faudrait effectivement que la mer
permettent aussi notamment aux
plaisanciers de de découvrir
l'arrière-pays parce que c'est le
comment non non c'est pas un projet dont
je jouais juste dire pour vous dire
effectivement aujourd'hui et déportant
que l'économie bleu et est une économie
nécessaire le développement de la
martinique
d'accord nous avions tellement du temps
de monsieur le monsieur r non je ne suis
pas été mais non mais non notre juste
moi parler monsieur les deux puisque ce
sont des deux ans et ex élu de la ville
d'accord nous avons ne prend pas du
centre nautique
d'accord nous avions une dame qui
s'occupait cas bénins souci assure que
bendtner cycle a simplement la mère n'a
pas été développée d'accord aucune
supporter celle des données à cette
personne dort c'est quelqu'un de privés
qui avait monté une structure si vous
l'avez les dirigeants les enfants où les
enfants faisaient du kayak voyez donc
alors quand on parle de harley glénan
pourquoi parce que nous allons dans le
projet glénat bacon en fait un club où
des glénan antimissile qui viendra dans
l'hexagone qui viendra qui viendra
s'occuper de les arrêter de former des
commandes et des jeunes martiniquais
n'avait pas certains non je vous
interromps pas je vous dis d'aller un
peu plus vite dans l'explication vous
avez déjà beaucoup d'avant centre
je vais me taire non parce que je vais
continuer mais résumer résumé juste dire
que ça c'est un faux procès d'accord
c'est le procès de ceux qui ne qui n'ont
pas de propositions à faire
mais qu'est ce que vous lui le vrai
procès oui mais voulait rebondir tout de
suite les alliés mais bien sur les i
joël joseph met alors en deux parties
intervenantes des parties alors je vais
parler d'abord du club nautique
monsieur j me parle du club nautique a
parlé d'une dame d'une dame comme si
qu'on n'ait pas la dame
c'est une jeune de sainte-anne employé
municipal après municipal qui faisait
tourner le club nautique et à former des
dizaines et des dizaines de cette année
à la voile au kayak à la natation
et qu'est ce que ce monsieur a trouvé de
bois fer de vie cette dame là pourquoi
pour mettre en place une association qui
sont de bretagne
moi je dis que c'est vrai mais prix pour
acheminer cette année et je vais le
préciser tout à l'heure de toutes les
associations de c'est un monsieur j'ai
bu n'a que du mépris pour avec les gens
avec qui il a fonctionné puisqu'il est
de cette année avec plaisir avec la
fonctionner ce qu'on comprend pas le
comportement de monsieur j'ai mieux et
magazines partie concernant la plage la
part marin pour vous avez parlé des
guinéens il faut bien savoir ce qu'il ya
derrière
c'était soit c'est une mascarade le fait
de dire effectivement que c'est un club
nautique et qu'on va pouvoir développer
la voie bleue tout ça moi ça c'est des
foutaises ça le vrai la vraie raison de
la présence des glénan c'est le cheval
de troie monsieur partie vous devez
connaître monsieur k o le cheval de
troie oui c'est bien la légende mais
vous connaissez bien bien voir
exactement le cheval de troie qui arrive
à l'apôtre malin parce que derrière ça
et à la rive accusations de toute la
bretagne y compris le coping en fait
quand vous dites le joual 3 c'est
l'arbre qui cache une forêt près c'est à
dire qu'on se sert de ce club des glénan
et pour faire rentrer d'autres rives
attisé pour voir ce monsieur monsieur
j'ai mieux et on traite de folle de la
haute marais comme le club n a été fait
du temps de monsieur on ne parlera
il fait du temps le méchant vicieux je
peux vous le dire d'ores et déjà
commencé pensions qu'on appelle c'est
pour ça qu'on appelle la bande de gaza
il connaît très bien la bande de gaza
alors moi en tant que conseiller
municipal bon je peux apporter d'autres
éléments concernant ce projet
effectivement nous constatons que
lorsque le sujet me parle
d'investissements il est permis de se
demander est-ce que ce qu'il ce qu'il
fait ce qu'il projette va dans l'intérêt
de cette année et c'est la première
question qu'il faut pour qu'on se pose
et pour arriver à la problématique du
glénan voilà-t-il pas que nous votons au
conseil municipal
en fait on dit la problématique de
grenoble du club nautique le club
nautique de 2,7
whissell donc il ya plusieurs éléments
qui nous font comme des risques et nous
font qu'ils nous posent réflexion
premièrement le centre nautique
d'écouter ses 5000 euros le matériel est
prévue pour 600 millions nous envoûter
ce projet de budget au niveau du conseil
municipal imaginez vous que les glénan
auront la jouissance de ses 1 million
d'euros d'investissement pour un euro
symbolique
c'est déjà pas mal aucune association ne
peut
se prévaloir d'avoir un tel privilège
mais un port dans le contrat de la
convention que le coup de passer il est
question de donner à cette association
10000 euros par an pendant trois ans
donc cela cela veut dire cela veut dire
que non seulement les as toutes les
associations
je sais pas diminuer ses 5000 et où
toutes les associations de sainte anne
où ses 4000 euros en tout lors du
conseil municipal
nous avons émis l'idée nous avons
proposé à monsieur le maire par exemple
et du vent on donne à vos associations
une subvention tous les ans il faut à
les supplier pour donner pour qu'ils
puissent donner cette subvention
alors je dis puisque vous avez une
convention semblait jusqu'à privilégie
un club sérieux avec entre guillemets de
léger à crier au loup
je vous cite des faits oui mais ce défi
vous allez conclure vous avez conclu par
nous les ait sortis nous écouter quand
je parle de vous je parle de toute la
population et particulièrement les
simples et cette année donc ça veut dire
qu' une seule association à une
convention sur trois ans nous disons bon
termites et par exemple ailleurs et
douvan d'ailleurs il y avait une copine
qui m'avait dit en trois ans nous car
bientôt là jeudi admettons mais tom est
un projet en cours disant moins de 3 ans
vous êtes assurés d'avoir dix mille 2000
ou 20000 euros pour vous pouvoir vous
permettre d'arriver à ce que votre à
votre
ni votre projet et donc non ça a été
refusé
donc ce qui revient à dire effectivement
qu'on privilégie plus ceux qui viennent
de l'extérieur que les pourpres cette
année et je n'ai pas encore parlé et je
n'aime pas parler de qu'est-ce qu'est ce
qu'ils vont nous proposer deux
animateurs qui va coûter que vont coûter
75 mille euros par an pour pouvoir
apprendre à nos enfants à faire de la
voile alors d'où la question à 7 ans de
panissars vauquelin pas renier sa foi
soit passé sans une question fausse
manipulation bien vieillir vous me
connaissez bien la lettre de garcin
malsa elle était adressée au maire
finalement de la lettre de monsieur
kacem a adressé une lettre à propos des
glénan effectivement en tant que maire
honoraire de la ville de sainte-anne
s'étonner du peu de considération leur
espace avec ses canards etc bref non
monsieur je dire savez savez même
interpellé le l'ancien maire quoi celui
qui vous précède cette affaire là gilles
bayle mots non loin sur cette affaire du
centre nautique de cinq ans j'ai à dire
c'est que il nécessité quand même pour
une ville comme cette année d'avoir un
club de voile mais on voit très bien que
les choix politiques de la municipalité
sortante sont très graves
o la martinique et poulets cette année
tout cas je pense besoin d'une nouvelle
approche politique d'une nouvelle
conception politique d'une nouvelle
posture politique à cette haine parce
que moi je dis nous disons notre lit ce
qu'à compétences égales
il faut privilégier les locaux et
d'abord les cette année mais est ce que
vous auriez comment est ce que ça veut
dire qu'il ya des candidats qui auraient
pu se positionner qui se sont
positionnés qui n'ont pas été retenus
que le meilleur en privilégier
volontairement une entreprise enfin une
association qui fonctionne comme une
entreprise avec les ingénieurs de
l'extérieur mais c'est parti vous savez
très bien que il ya des règles en
matière d'attribution de marché donc
nous verrons en temps voulu les
conditions de l'attribution de ce marché
les particuliers ce marché il n'a connu
qu'un seul postulant en fait
expliquez nous comment vous avez été
amené à donner il a attribué le marché à
ce club fait la candide qui vient de
quelle ville d'ailleurs des nappes la
candidature qui a été qui a été fait
d'accord toute la martinique à une
publicité qui était fait et les glénan
et tourner la seule soutient avoir
répondu tu as quoi
si monsieur de quelle ville si monsieur
je sais pas si c'est d'abord s'ils sont
brutales et entretenant d'accord ok
était loisible à tout à chacun de se
présenter pourquoi ça n'a pas été fait
nous avons été appelés même chaîne
cherche et n'a pas pu dire venez où est
le problème
deuxièmement veut faire un procès aux
maires parce que le maire de simplement
mettre les enfants fameux la liste des
dix ans avec la mer
moi je ne comprends pas que le procès
face à lui un contrôle de légalité tout
a été fait en bonne et due forme
d'accord alors il s'agit pas de tomber
dans des excès de deux verbes et
monsieur j'avais des qualités vous allez
tribune distractives comme le dit très
bien monsieur bailly vous jouez plus
quand même été une opa du tribunal pour
faire invalider la situation de néoules
en tout cas tout a été fait en
respectant et en tourisme dont le tout
aujourd'hui on peut me faire un procès
et parce que des martin qui ne se sont
pas positionnés sur cette affaire l'a
écouté alors voir que par l'autre un
autre thème de la campagne parce que là
on peut pas faire de l'édition
j'ai très peu de déception notre intérêt
notre but tout à ces pierres à lire
toute action toute action municipale
doit aller dans l'intérêt de la
population
et là nous savons très bien que nous
pouvons faire autrement nous pouvons
former nouveau rapport par rapport à
ceux à ceux associés âgées vous auriez
été maire de saint-amand
oyez vous procéder différemment jouer je
connais d'ailleurs nous avons d'ailleurs
nous avons de notre projet nous aurons à
définir quelques quelques axes nous nous
aurons effectivement permis la recherche
d'animateurs compétents qui existent en
martinique
et puis ce quitte à faire une
association régie pour permettre de
développer comme la seule la seule
animatrice qui étaient là faisait de
travail qu'on est censé donner à faire
aux glénan donc si on l'avait appuyé
avec deux membres deux animateurs issus
de la ville de sainte anne qui sont
formés on ne serait pas arrivé là mais
c'est joseph joseph et finissent
rapidement avant de passer à une autre
religion
oui monsieur partie pourquoi j'ai
insisté sur ce point là parce que la
dame d'autre part l'animatrice
monsieur j me connaît très bien elle
approchait sisley pour le club nautique
elle m'a montré le projet jojo parfaite
j'ai pu poser moyens elle a un projet si
donc si effectivement on avait un tant
soit peu sollicités jeudi me pas alger
je vous mariage ou voeckler jeune âge
est à 7 mm
il ya un poco deux projets qui existent
à cette haine qui se trouve à cette
halle
c'est pourquoi je ne comprends pas la
volonté de monsieur le maire de casse de
sortie tout de suite cette personne de
là où il est je rappelle qui a formé bon
nombre de cette année et des jeunes qui
cette année ont passé le bac est
effectivement obtenu des notes un
magistral en matière est déjà choisi
caiap exemple alors voit le résultat on
est à 30 minutes donc des missions il
nous reste peu de temps donc vous voulez
pour conclure je voudrais que papa
consommer montant de
de fait un bond rapide moi bah si
j'essaye faudrait que vous arrêtiez les
gars arrêtez de mentir et cetera on
parle de jules nra-zo et l'a vu cette
femme effectivement avait une
association d'accord et celles qui
avaient investi dans l'ensemble du
matériel vous n'avez pas aidé quand vous
parlez de cette indépendance qu'elle
avoue desquels vous comme ça je suis
monsieur b vous que vous parlez quand
vous parlez de neuf interventions comme
opérations que vous parlez vous aviez le
capitalisme bon qu'à trouver des bourses
ont déjoué huet était de l'extérieur ah
ouais ouais mais c'est toi j les
étrangers nous intéresse pas les avis
étaient des étrangers
voilà des étrangers mais je voudrais pas
qu'on dise à des négationnistes
étrangers
voilà c'est ce que j'ai dit pichot de
quoi de l'extérieur de quoi j'ai
simplement voulu dire du système
exceptionnel unique politique la
longueur breton cinq hommes dont ils ont
fait venir à lloret comme par la
pochette de ce panneau est ce que vous
rendez pas en france par le magazine a
été arrêté quand même monsieur vous êtes
vous êtes dans un pays de droit
vous n'êtes pas français on a de la pop
était chez nous monsieur chine a conclu
sur ce sujet jean marcou rappelle 410 et
dans le club de handball qui fait les
beaux jours du choc comme ce monsieur
mais devrait savoir que ces 7 1 410 et
non cap 110 car sony c'est autre chose
c'était mais molex se trouve audika la
revitalisation du centre bon comme vous
du centre-ville appelons le comme vous
voulez qui y pose des difficultés à ces
dames comme dans beaucoup de communes
qui ont un bourg historique qui devient
trop étriqué par rapport aux besoins de
la population par rapport à la
circulation automobile par rapport à
l'expansion économique le commerce le
tourisme et donc comment faire ensemble
pour redémarrer la mesure où sainte anne
c'est l'une des communes où on le voit
très nettement une open fracture mais
une une ses yeux une séparation entre
les quartiers ruraux et le centre-ville
c'est paris c'est pas une critique c'est
un constat et comme cette année dans ce
cas également comment faire pour
redonner le ce
retrouvez un regain d'attractivité à
partir du centre-ville pour irriguer
tous les autres quartiers de sainte anne
est ce que ce n'est pas là également un
projet de mandat un monsieur pourquoi
pas est ce qu'il ya des réflexions des
projets ont fait sourire
gilles bellemare peut-être là-dessus je
rappelle qu'on a entendu d'ailleurs
quelques personnes interviewées
interrogé par kkr et ola olé entendu
tout à l'heure deux au moins on dit ont
regretté qu'il n'y ait pas assez
d'animations 1 à sainte-anne alors j'ai
pas animations ce parce que ça recouvre
exactement mais enfin voilà donc gibel
mots alors fait clair que le centre
bourse doit être le poumon de l'activité
économique nous la lys un nouvel élan
tout sainte-anne et clients notre ville
dans notre programme
on va proposer notamment que le marché
aux légumes et aux fruits qui est un
petit peu éloigné du centre bourg soit
transférée sur la place qu'on appelle le
22 mai pour recréer une dynamique au
coeur du beau et là où il existe
actuellement devra être plus tôt
affectée à des places de stationnement
et à partir de là à partir de là on va
créer des animations pour rendre la
ville attractive pour rendre la ville
animée ou la rendre effective en criant
de nouveaux concepts autour des
commerçants existants des commerces
existants il faut effectivement que
cette ville
comme on l'a dit soit lumineuse et rions
anciennement c'est elle qui éclaire et
le sud des caraïbes
oui mais attendez il ya de la
concurrence mais au marin il ya beaucoup
de touristes ou de martinique et qui
voudraient bien les instants mais qui
sont accaparés par le marin qui se
développe cependant pas de sens plus
avant le mariage sans plus
et puis il y à d'autres endroits qui
commence à attirer du monde comme
vauquelin par exemple qui fait beaucoup
d'efforts depuis quelques années donc
est ce que ce n'est pas illusoire de
croire que c'est un homme va reprendre
le lustre d'antan puisque les autres
mais n'ont pas entendu le développement
de cette non c'est clair mais nous avons
des ressources qui sont est comparable
le plan do la baie de sainte anne les
plages dont vous avez n'oublie c'est la
baie de sainte anne où la baie du marin
non non lavé de ses trades non ça
c'était s'est implanté aux vocations en
amical mais c'est top le dos pour les
marines on a surtout qui n'a pas
d'équivalence donc autour de ça il faut
crier des événements spécifiques recréer
de la dynamique pour faire venir les
gens qui anciennement venait à s'étendre
mais ce que c'est le rôle du maire ou du
conseil municipal ou est ce que c'est le
rôle les entreprises privées des
commerçants des initiatives
la municipalité doit doit avec l'appui
de la communauté d'agglomération de
l'espace sud qui qui a la compétence
développement économique trouver des
outils pour crier c'est cet attrait là
oui oui cavaillon vaucluse ne conseil
municipal
l'ancien ancien mandat avec un salaire
aussi municipal aussi de ce bruit en
effet vous êtes six minutes fait
d'opposition à voyez vous m loyer vie
sur une position était dans la majorité
avant lundi cap actuel ne date pas d'il
ya six mois il ya séquence est beaucoup
plus ancien ce sont des mouvements très
lent de dynamiser ou de perdre l'attrait
d'un autre centre ville on en avait
conquis c'est justement cet attrait
c'est peut-être parce que je je je me
souviens que au mois de décembre les
touristes prenaient l'eau billets pour
assister par exemple à la crèche vivante
donc c'était c'était une manifestation
qui était qui était manquée qui était
comme comme la belle au niveau de
certaines les gros marchés et pour
parler de d'animation moi je pense qu'
il ne faut pas se focaliser uniquement
sur le bourg nous avons tous les
quartiers où il ya une population
importante qui mérite d'être aussi
redynamiser nous parlons par exemple de
cap chevalier le cap chevalier
nous avons des pêcheurs qui il ya six
ans que la disputer à glace est en panne
et aérien s'est passé pas entretenu
alors qu'il ya un passage de tous alors
que nous avons des agents économiques
qui fonctionne là déjà l'activité
c'est aussi dans les quartiers dans les
quartiers pour permettre aux jeunes de
commander âge de s'occuper nous nous
préconisons un plein au niveau culture
sports loisirs qui va englober tous les
quartiers dans le cadre la démocratie
participative qui vont englober tous les
quartiers pour permettre à chaque achat
quartier de disques de définir ses
besoins au niveau 2 au niveau de
l'animation
et puis au niveau des possibilités qu'il
est qu'ils ont que ne l'avouent pas fait
avant comme se tient au pouvoir
mais si je viens de vous dire que nous
l'avons nous l'avions puisqu'elle a
perdu si je vous dis je vous dis que si
j'avoue si j'avoue je garde si je vous
dis que la sainte anne a perdu de sa
notoriété a perdu de son éclat c'est
parce qu'elle avait avant alors
considérez vous que c'est bizarre c'est
depuis six ans
si vous voulez dire depuis l'élection de
monsieur j'ai mieux
j'étais j'ai été abandonné au niveau de
l'office municipal des sports et de la
culture
nous avons nous avions une programmation
annuelle où toutes les semaines c'est
comme c'est comme trois semaines minimum
nous avons toutes les semaines des
animations dans les quartiers au niveau
culturel au niveau sportif au niveau de
loisirs là il ya pratiquement et saufs
l'église quelques mois qui suivent ce
qui précède élection où on a vu une
pléthore de manifestation sans sens
effectivement de se désister avant que
ça fonctionnait bien
la population vous à sanctionner n'a pas
validé a voulu faire autre chose ils
vont recommencer voulait recommencer ce
qui a été sanctionnée c'est à dire que
vous me dites est ce que la la la la
population spécial rien que le nom qu'on
m'a dit qu'avant il y avait des choses
intéressantes il y avait la démocratie
participative qui fonctionnaient les
quantités animée on vous avait perdu les
élections il ya six ans pourquoi vous
l'oubliez vous refaire ce qui existait
avant qui aurait soi-disant manche est
d'après vous que la population n'a pas
validé par les autres activités
oui voilà l'activité ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas une notion qui avant ou après
ce que nous disons que nous allons
mettre en place des éléments un projet
pour plusieurs artistes la ville et j'y
reviens mais qu'on arrive effectivement
au projet pour vous permettre de
constater qu'elles sont des exemples
projets que nous avons mis mes mais ne
sommes pas là pour faire la lutte aux
psys de ce clip qui est passé nous
sommes aujourd'hui en train de constater
la dégradation depuis six ans de la
ville de sainte anne la gabégie la
gabégie non fausse arrivée là parce que
oui parce que c'est les autres
j'aime bien si on la met sur la table
les chats les i je suis parti nous avons
18 minutes de ce soir dit vous avez
parlé du marin vous avez parlé de cette
crise on a dit qu'il ya des communes pas
loin qui oui mais cet argent leur attire
cette ânerie
la voir avec le marin c'est en a rien à
voir avec cette puce qualité en matière
de ressources en matière d'environnement
naturel donc sans talent peut
concurrencer ses voisines mais de loups
en faisant autre chose dans ce pays
atteints des mêmes mais de louer elle va
faire l'horizon en valorisant ses
richesses nous avons un plan d'eau est
comparable
sur le plan du bourg avec les falaises
du panorama ma foi il ya tout ce qu'il
faut pour créer des événements pour
créer de l'attractivité pour faire d y
revenir et surtout monsieur parti
prendre soin de ses acteurs économiques
à cette année c'est le harcèlement c'est
la guerre comme si j'ai mieux même avec
des acteurs économiques je dis que c'est
pas normal c'est intolérable
mais à moi mais with il harcèle mais
c'est tim la guerre il repose toujours
des choses aux acteurs économiques
présents péché travail et mènent la vie
dure vous le dire ce sera peut-être plus
qu'a duré la guerre karine mais j'ai
mieux roulé qui passe son temps qui
passe son temps à faire ça moi moi moi
je vous dis en tant que maire je vais
prendre soin de la santé des acteurs
économiques
parce ce sont des partenaires parce que
des partenaires économiques des acteurs
économiques qui sont en bonne santé ce
sont des acteurs qui vont investir qui
vont innover qui vous créiez des emplois
qui vont animer la ville si on voyait
donc c'est un tout qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire il faut préparer le terreau et
poule il faut faire ce qu'il a à faire
on a la chance d'avoir des joyaux on a
le plan d'eau on a le marché
effectivement aux imprimés sub elmo et
effectivement bon c'est à les petits bon
peut-être rêvé que nous avons les mêmes
idées mais effectivement on al'intention
de replacer le marché mais surtout
surtout surtout vous avez palier delà de
la salette monsieur particulier il
pénètre la salette
chaque année la somme 11 ans
le pèlerin eh bien voyez ce site de la
salette
il sera transformé ceux ci doivent
former un lourd à 3 de la salette à nous
à 3 de la fin on va faire venir les
pèlerins à cette année on va faire
revenir les prêts parce que le tourisme
le tourisme à développer la culture et
le patrimoine serait développé jean
michel j'ai mieux juste des plus de
discours n'a pas changé depuis 25 ans
toujours les mêmes insanités les mêmes
propos on parle fort on fait du bruit et
on pense que ça fait science là c'est le
projet parce que les gens ces personnes
disent effectivement on va faire mais
disent pas comment ils vont faire il pas
avec quels moyens
quelle contribution yvon ferland mais
ici ils vont faire mais moi j'ai fait
déjà par deux des mois nous avez fait
pour décider à lancer pour dynamiser
redynamiser le avant le projet avant le
projet ce que vous avez fait au cours
des six dernières années les taux
allaient tous rallier la ville va aussi
vous faites de la profondeur des lettres
les élections c'est moi d'accord mais
c'est monsieur je vais vous donner déjà
les deux minutes parce que je vais pas
pour consommer montant non mais les
premières première question nous avons
fait six ponts nous avons sécurisé les
legends la wii avait ça fâche était fait
et d'athlètes est terminée nous avons
aussi les quartiers désenclaver les
quartiers nous avons assuré une voix une
voix reid est meilleur d'accord les
enfants les l'amiante
les écologistes ici présents vous aviez
de la vie à l'école maternelle
en clair certainement nous avons des
personnes des personnes âgées pour de
travail là les atsem qui subissent les
contrecoups de l'amiante les infos si
ces deux là nous avons visé depuis 97
mais nous si vous saviez qu'avait de
l'alien on n'avait pas bougé on parle
d'écologie g le balisage a été fait en
pleine bourre de façon à ce que les
voitures et les bateaux ce mois au de
l'inversion de droit se met d'accord
nous avons fait un superbe montre le
niveau d'aidé comment dirais-je des
employés nous avons des personnes que
dernier pas le smic horaire
nous allons titulariser pas de 17
personnes d'accord nous avons réglé les
primes antérieurement que les blés les
personnes guéries
les titulaires avec prime aujourd'hui
quasiment toute la populace tous les
employés les conditions de travail sont
différents d'accord excités de vous
savez j'ai un là à vous voulez parler de
votre projet mais voilà parce que ces
messieurs disent qu'ils vont faire de
moi je dis que j'ai fait déjà non c'est
pas ça c'est pareil c'est pareil non
celle là c'est la même chose nous dit
alors le travail avec la dure mais c'est
quoi ce projet c'est effectivement
amélioré leur samedi 22 mai j'aimerais
bien c'est qu'il ya une sorte de plage
urbaine d'accord et créer des structures
de effectivement ce que les gens
puissent créer créer une animation mais
que les âges économique aussi trouvent
leur lot et de même temps mettre les
jeunes ne se tanne au travail d'ailleurs
la marée puisque je me suis dit qu'on va
vendre ça je sais pas d'où sort cette
affaire-là
nous avons crié 12 petits kiosques
privatiser la sas et des paroles de
politique politicienne début de deux
personnes qui ont quelques difficultés à
rester debout jamais dire venant à la
culture peut venir selon la culture
monsieur était directeur dont il parlait
de monsieur monsieur les haïr billets
parce qu'on parle oui il veut il pas il
parle effectivement de culture etc
il faut conclure nous a laissé 2,5 à 2
206 milles euros de dettes
ces clauses sociales monsieur à dire
qu'il parle il agit aussi qu'ici est
donc je prends d'attendre et je vais ici
nous avons pu parler après nous avons
également où ce monsieur avec mondiale
rochon reliquat de salaire de 3000 sein
quelques euros monsieur ça y est c'est
l'homme qui était le bleu bleu comme le
dit le président le président de
l'office de demande de l'une de ses
victimes en une journée là il a fait 10
à la décence combien revient de plein
vous demande c'est le plein 17 17
le rapport mondial de coups de fil à la
police at il dit cela je vais faire dans
le jeu monsieur monsieur monsieur j'ai
mieux 210 milliards d'émissions argent
nous avons nous arrivons à les coupes
nous avons à l'écouter on veut y
remédier le spectre de spectateurs de
spectateurs monsieur j'ai mieux vielles
de dire que monsieur aiea a fait 17
plein d'essence avec le véhicule
le csc encore avec le mensonge sur
mensonge je n'ai jamais utilisé
vous avez dit que vous allez attaquer en
diffamation mais il faut dire que je
n'ai jamais conduit de cette voiture
j'avais alors voilà voilà la méthode on
va reparler de votre projet chacun va
présenter son projet prioritaire mais
j'ai une question comme on l'a refait de
l'émission oui rapidement une réponse
très courte monsieur meredith c'est
monsieur zaïre vous vous êtes tous les
deux militants donc à l'assaut pamart
vous n'êtes pas vous êtes tous les deux
des militants écologistes donc vous
n'êtes pas à vous n'avez pas réussi à
vous entendre pour ce scrutin pour cette
échéance 2020 pourquoi vous ne puissiez
commune sur les acteurs l'eau doit
s'interroger s'il ya des accusations qui
ont été portées
il ya des mois sont inscrits mais ça
vous avez répondu j'avais donc j'ai dit
que j'avais tout su séduire ce n'est pas
le problème vous bougez pas cela peut
vous poser cette question comme je peux
je peux vous dire que je ne répondrai
pas à cette question de la mesure où
nous avons très peu de temps pour
exposer notre programme et ils vous avez
rapidement
monsieur je t'ai pas répondre à cette
question monsieur des sélectionnés pour
moi ce n'est pas important
maintenant il ya trois ans à répondre ou
gêner cette tenir cette facture doit
bien sûr
hebbadj est en tout cas moi je me savais
que ce fait nous avoir posé une question
gênante au projet vous dites que vous ne
s'est pas intéressant non je peux vous
mais j'ai des choses à les assurer
vous allez dire sur autre chose mais
monsieur m avec votre permission
messieurs de faire un point d'orgue pour
dire qu'il nous reste onze minutes
d'émission que nous vous demandons
maintenant d'envisager de nous présenter
brièvement votre projet prioritaire
parce que nous aurons nous n'avons pas
quatre heures d'émission d'avant non
pour que chacun puisse présenter son
programme bien entendu ce n'est pas le
but de l'exercice
et vous n'aurez pas le temps la
population de septembre sera à votre
écoute pendant toute la campagne donc
votre projet prioritaire celui qui vous
tient le plus à coeur que vous pensez
être le plus fédérateur je crois que
monsieur réunissant avec rappelle moi
qui est très en retard par rapport à
vous donc je voulais avant de parler de
mon projet de notre projet priorité aux
dire que concernant l'attractivité du
territoire
on considère que c'est primordial donc
on va créer si nous sommes élus une
direction chargé de l'attractivité du
territoire avec un adjoint qui sera qui
va chapeauter ça et c'est vrai que tous
les autres candidats ont parlé de la
pression qui est exercée est d'emblée si
nous sommes élus nous allons suspendre
les procédures judiciaires et juste à
lanton des acteurs économiques de cette
année parce qu'il ya eu bon nombre de
procès qui ont été engagés pied avec les
honorer en l'argent des contribuables
cette année
aujourd'hui on considère qu' un certain
nombre de procédures sont totalement et
juste nous allons les suspendre pour
restaurer un climat de confiance et le
dialogue avec ces acteurs économiques
parce que si on veut de la hollande si
on veut recréer des emplois il faut
travailler en parant nitrates
partenariat avec ces acteurs économiques
s'est pas la commune qui peut
aujourd'hui est créateur d'emplois
deuxièmement nous allons aussi suspens
deux arrêtés municipaux qui ont été pris
pour interdire l'installation de tables
et de chaises sur les plages de la
poutre marais du bo à l'on compte encore
des restaurateurs ce sont des décisions
importantes pour créer de la relance je
constate que certains nombre de
restaurateurs qui ont pignon sur rue sur
l'après marée condé beaucoup de familles
qui veut s'installer compte tenu de leur
capacité
ils sont obligés de refuser ces clients
là parce que deux arrêtés ont été pris
parce qu'ils avaient installé des tables
des chaises et des parasols sur la plage
nous nous il faut que ça s'arrête à
sainte anne
il faut motiver des acteurs économiques
alors le projet qui mérite elle craque
et s'écrie une nouvelle recette fiscale
à sainte anne avec la b il faut
organiser cette baie il faut dégager
c'est ce cet obstacle visuel les mains
les bateaux qu'on voit là chaque bateau
qui entre nous à binh nourri aux récifs
chaque bateau qui en nous laisse de la
pollution
chaque bateau qui ancre ne paie
strictement rien jusqu'à ce jour dans la
baie de sept heures et y prennent l'eau
dès cette année ils déposent leurs
ordures
ben il faut organiser une zone de
mouillage organisée
pour très rapidement crié nouvel os est
créé de l'emploi écrit une nouvelle
dynamique à cette année oui alors oui
alors justement concernant la mère c'est
un vecteur d'emploi qui est très très
important et nous ça fait partie de
notre thème de thèmes forts de notre
programme c'est l'emploi durable
les quotidiens l'éco citoyenneté et la
cohésion sociale donc nous avons en
commun une ambition de faire un plan
d'urgence pour l'emploi durable
bien sûr la commune de poids pas ne
pouvait pas en bouger tout le monde mais
nous avons créé les conditions pour
permettre en s'appuyant sur les atouts
de sainte anne je donne quelques
exemples au niveau de la production
production alimentaire biologique
cette annonce est une terre sans trop
d'icônes nous pouvons faire une filière
agroalimentaire de transformation de
production sur ce label terre sont
chlordécone est donc c'est une c'est un
élément que nous avons que nous avons au
niveau des activités nautiques
effectivement la ccl pouvoir d'emploi en
prestation de service combien de cette
année sont sont spécialistes de
l'accastillage ce cas si jal ça veut
dire que nous aurons à mettre en place d
un plan de formation sur tous les
métiers que nous aurons identifiez vous
permettre à de jeunes martin jeunes
c'est un jeune martiniquais de pouvoir
bénéficier de cette de ce2 ce2 se
cet aspect de cet aspect de l'activité
nautique l'aide à la personne
effectivement nous aurons aussi du fait
de la programme que vous envisagez vous
donne quelques petits jeux c'est bon et
émotion et puis nous avons surtout le
met en place pour étouffer tout ça un
plan de formation et de chantier
d'insertion que nous mettons en place
notre projet parce que parce que nous
disons que nous allons reconstruire nous
allons faire mais il faut pas oublier
que c'est en le maire qui va remplacer
monsieur g messieurs c'est mieux ou a à
gérer un endettement de 6 millions d'un
point à 2,6 millions d'un point s'est
mis au point et il se plaignait avant
d'avoir deux millions de factures lui
aussi est en décembre 2018 et a été
coupée et vous pouvez le voir et j'ai
ici les documents de la direction
générale des finances qui dit qu'en fin
2018 il ya eu 2 millions dans de dettes
et soit 176 euros et un extrait du
procès-verbal de 2
de pousser municipal monsieur pierre
ayot considère qu'on a pas répondu à sa
question relative au niveau
d'endettement global bancaire de ce
budget monsieur sisi je ne dit pas son
nom c'est un fonctionnaire indique qu'il
y à 2 millions d'encours de crédit
ajouter aux 4 millions quatre cent 400
milles
cela fait 6 millions quatre cent mille
euros de vêtements cours d'eau avec ça
nous pouvons dire que nous allons faire
beaucoup de choses mais nous avons
d'avoir réglé ce problème de ce que nous
avons arriver monsieur joseph joël
joueuses merelli que c'est votre projet
prioritaire alors que vous somme leur
hymne le plus porteur oui - c'est un
exercice très difficile
rien n'est moins sûr il y en a plusieurs
ya dénombré onze projets calmement et
lauren levi's et en trois secteurs le
secteur du grand beau et sa périphérie
le secteur du grand cap hockey et puis
les huiles et sa ligne alors concernant
le boulot sans trop vous jouez bien et
aimait parler effectivement de la roue
localisation de notre marché au niveau
de la place de 22me actuelle mais comme
monsieur belmont on a déjà parlé
je vais simplement ajouté que ce
bâtiment qui sera construit va s'appeler
l'atrium du vendee pas ce non seulement
à l'intérieur et wall e manche local st
cyr a transformé des parkings à l'entrée
et à la sortie du mot le packing si j'ai
le temps de parler de vous et vous
expliquer devant le stade de la porte
marins pour beaucoup mais attends mais
tu n'es pas au rendez vous que mon
projet alors est il va pas chômer plus
il me faut si vous avez une minute pour
terminer allez-y monsieur vous ne
pourrez pas développer la procédure
ces projets prioritaires le prix que
cela développement du il faut il faut
animer le bourg 7
il faut obtenir les gens qui visitent la
commune et bien voilà avec l'atrium du
vin dubé sera sur la % à l'intérieur
effectivement un grand podium et au
grand écran et des commerces à
l'intérieur effectivement on pourra
faire des expositions
voilà et surtout surtout les pauvres à
la sécurité et je fais un petit coucou à
monsieur albert poncelet tous nos
projets surtout dans ce très beau
et il va être question non sans race
humaine question de c'est pas ça
seulement mais de protection contre les
chutes pas protection auprès des amis
aussi voilà pour le synami tout ça voilà
joël à paris monsieur vous avez déjà
évoqué en premier projet jamais agir de
ti pa stephen jen est il simplement dire
ceci annulation de l'oreille de monsieur
pierre aïm relatives à l'allocation de
parcelles à val d'or la consigne est de
faire d'économie parce que monsieur
pierre haïr a bénéficié à l'absence de
sonde du maire grâce emma zone de
l'époque effectivement d'une
délibération prise par son cousin pour
l'exonérer de tde tiens qui n'est pas
payé depuis un moment monsieur pierre à
lire aussi c'est un homme effectivement
qui ont parlé des connaissances et si je
me suis aussi qui me doit et doit la
place vous pouvez pas laisser ça puisque
moins de 1500 euros
c'est de la diffamation mais joie
tellement voulait laisser les peines on
sait rien si vous voulez que le
contredire vous allez et puis si vous
êtes si vous estimez que c'est faux ce
qu'il a dit mais vous portez jamais rien
je n'ai rien à dire parce que monsieur
monsieur chat michel j'ai mieux a
effectivement cette méthode cette
méthode de sortir de son chapeau des
choses comme ça et comme par hasard une
scierie et clochers justifie rien
projets prioritaires projets priorité
effectivement je voudrais me dire
monsieur bruno qu'il faut qu'ils
arrêtent effectivement de quoi que tout
ce qu'on lui dit la loi littoral est là
pour vous dire tant de choses la loi
jemmapes il a aussi informé vous alors
quand vous allez dans les restaurants
pour simplement prendre le pouls et ben
oui il ya des gens ne peut pas permettre
moi je suis d'accord à ce que je suis
les plages qu'il n'y ait pas de deux
transats qu'il ait pas de table parce
que effectivement c'est important que
les efforts soient à l'aise concernant
le projet nous avons alors je voudrais
simplement dire autre chose quand on
fait un impôt est aussi d'accord quand
on a une tête d'accor une décret de
l'actif une détresse darty vous achetez
une maison que vous payez un mot donné
vous avez un actif alors que les garçons
sont frileuses de points qu'ils avaient
à développer ce qu'on va développer le
projet d'accord est ce pas d'aménagement
touristique est victime d'accord nous
avons déjà
commencer nous avons une certaine sncb
se mettre en place dron vers le câble
supplémentaire de la prochaine version
vous avez aussi la l'école du bourg
d'accord qui sera en vue nous avons
autre délibération peut débrancher de
deux millions deux cent mille euros pour
recréer cette école dans le boue nous
avons aussi l'éclairage
nous avons aussi le manoir un million
six cent mille euros pour mettre les
gens au travail
d'accord pour former des jeunes d'accord
pour en même temps aussi créé l'activité
économique voilà la situation je vous
parlais du du 22 mai encore un exemple
et puis enfin pas un exemple mais vous
citez un projet encore et puis où
était-elle conclusions et anne les
dettes de sans attendre de ses parts
même quelques millions un million sept
cent mille euros
l'héroïne vous savez ce qui déborde
aussi c'est la capacité de
désendettement
d'accord nous avons une capacité à
hauteur de quatre années où ça me tue
voie orale mois 15 msv sur le j'aime
créer des entreprises d'accord ils sont
là et ne donne ses perpétuelles motus
bel et bien son ex-mari simpson si l'on
examine montrer qu'ils sont vraiment
d'accord
en 25 ans on peut enfin le procès d'un
homme qui pendant cinq à fait le maximum
tout ce que vous n'avez pas pu faire à
25 ans que cela vous plaise ou pas je
vous rappelle pouvaient être égaux
devant la mort et d'avoir pensé à fria
vous êtes à la ville terminé et vous la
tâche l'invitation comme la taxe le cg
comme la société vous service vous savez
c'est dur je sais du prochain écueil et
on passe aux conclusions
si vous le voulez bien pour terminer
donc voilà gilles bayle mot donc note
lis un nouvel élan tout cette ann ée
clients notre ville est une liste sans
étiquette politique qui va apporter un
vent de fraîcheur de simplicité et de
dynamisme donc on veut changer la
conception la conception la conception
c'est le moi je veux que ça soit bannie
ac thann c'est une équipe une équipe on
va s'appuyer sur des citoyens
c'est essentiellement des actifs qui
font partie de notre liste qui veulent
servir sainte anne avec le coeur
équitablement ou qu' on est des élus
qu'ils soient au service dès cette année
et de tous les sept années sans clan
sans clivage et vous avez vu nous sommes
nous allons prochainement
et bien pendant la campagne développer
toutes nos actions nos projets concrets
merci c'est au tour de joël joseph
merrill x de faire sa conclusion en une
minute s'il vous plaît voilà alors cette
année cette année zan sur le terrain
vous êtes nombreux à dire que tu as 2014
vous n'avez pas voté pour monsieur
j'aime chercher mieux vous avez voté
contre monsieur quand c'est mal ça
l'actuel président du modemas et je vous
ai compris
contrairement à d'autres je respecte
votre choix mais vous avez mis en place
mais par défaut avec tous les risques
que cela comporte
mais ce qui était prévisible est arrivé
c'est encore vous avez choisi qui dit il
était venu pour compter ses voix cachait
bien son jeu
et depuis son arrivée il nous montre son
vrai visage
reste qu'un souvent ses défauts ses apps
était surtout ses limites quand les bien
seul pour gérer efficacement la commune
de sainte anne
aujourd'hui on peut dire sans se tromper
qu'il est venu qu'il a vu faut conclure
mais voeckler ma saison il n'a pas vécu
il a surtout tout foutu en l'air dont
j'ai le calaisis mais en deux phrases 20
minutes est largement dépassée nous nous
venons avec accès à internet il est à
l'aise pouces d'abord en urgence tout de
suite faire approuver le plus qui
n'existaient pas ou retrouver notre
office du tourisme
merci trouver jemaa joseph non c'est pas
quotidien c'est une conclusion chacun
une minute vous pouvez pas moins de
trois minutes
jean-michel j'ai mieux oui désolé mais
c'est comme ça je voudrais dire aux
auditeurs effectivement vous aussi vous
avez qu'une minute minutes 10 à lui
de faire attention à toutes ces
personnes qui parlent toujours dans la
frise de phase et au logis le verbiage
une chose est certaine que les projets
sont là ils sont financés pour la marche
par acidd d'accord et c'est important
d'envisager les choses
ces personnes étaient au pouvoir ici
vous avez une même équipe qui ils y vont
tous de l'école les coupes de garcin
malsa monsieur bell mots et des
directeurs de l'assam sud cap où les
scènes sud qui nous a laissé une
enveloppe de 625 euros
626 millions que nous sommes et
messieurs les haïr pierre est au coin de
sa bouche alors c'est une conclusion
donc éviter les attaques que vous voyez
dans les 48 ce qui a été fait vous voyez
comment je suis un petit comment mon
équipe était expliqué comment la
situation venus rnr paie aujourd'hui à
sainte anne de corps des personnes sous
la peau fripée actuelle des turbulences
alors arrêtons cela vous ferez le bon
choix mais en tout cas nous revenait pas
en arrière parce que enfin plus tard
répétitrice gg je me permets je me
permets parce que c'est très grave
cette attaque encore au personnel qui
est pas ôté amont en croûte mais je dois
dire que de m6 je n'ai jamais été
directeur de la victoire n'est pas
trouvée match et j'ai été salarié de sm
sud quelques unes sommet les pays
doivent y ait en général de la seine sud
c'était l'ancien meilleur de cette année
donc et vous avez hérité de ce en tant
que meilleur si vous connaissez la
situation et les statuts faut pas
raconter n'est vraiment pas bien voilà
cdg c'est un président directeur général
comment il est l'actionnaire majoritaire
était la commune de sainte à doc c'est
vous qui connaissez son dos il fait ça
faut pas sortir n'importe quoi et donc
le tirage au sort a désigné pierre haïr
donc pour terminer les conclusions et
alors le débat alors cette année cette
année vous avez vu monsieur jean-michel
j'ai mieux est resté dans sa dimension
des insultes de calomnie et de
d'allégations sans fondement nous on
fait là mais pourtant potent non il
n'est pas question pour nous il n'est
pas question pour nous de continuer avec
cet homme qui a mito de gabégie à cette
année mais nous proposons nous au niveau
agir ensemble
pour certaines d'essayer de redynamiser
la ville de sainte anne mais aussi de
recréer le lien social qu'il acquit là
qu'il a détérioré par ces attaques de
haut niveau du harcèlement des
commerçants par mme comme les canadiens
de le dire et donc nous avons un projet
comme projet d' essayer de réunir de
rassembler les sept années pour pouvoir
aller le développement durable et
solidaire le à l'atelier de sainte anne
était faux le prix culture merci à vous
quatre gilles bayle mot jean-michel j'ai
mieux joël joseph marie dit que c'est
pierre haïr d'avoir participé à ce débat
d'avoir répondu à la plupart de nos
questions et puis on va terminer donc
avec jean marc g va nous rappeler les
quelques rendez vous à venir dans
l'actualité politique électorale en
signalant que ce débat très animé a été
réalisée en collaboration avec un niveau
oui et bien qu'à quartetto réalisé par
claudine était le biais avec
chronométrage aujourd'hui frédéric m'a
choqué la rédactrice en chef de
martinique la première les prochains
rendez vous avec nos débats sur nos
antennes la semaine prochaine tout
d'abord en radio encore et sur internet
lundi avec les candidats de cette marie
qui seront cinq ans télé le mardi 11 ce
sera avec les candidats du marin et nous
revenons radio vendredi prochain avec
les candidats de la ville de schoelcher
angola bertrand va bien merci pour votre
écoute votre attention et votre
confiance voilà ah oui je dois préciser
pardon je dois préciser parce que nous
avons une reprogrammation du débat de
marigot avec les cadets marigot à 20
heures après le journal télévisé donc à
21 ans martin promet en télé pour
pourrait voir le débat avec les quatre
candidats de marigot que nous devions
initialement diffusée mardi mais des
problèmes techniques nous ont contraints
à le repousser à aujourd'hui vendredi
donc à celles et ceux qui le souhaitent
pourront voir ce débat entre les
candidats du marigot en télé ce soir à
21 heures vendredi
merci là on a été complet
la première élection municipale le débat